Good morning everybody.
I'm Judy Singer.
I'm the senior vice provost
for faculty development
and diversity.
And I want to thank you all
for coming to this event
to talk about the
faculty search process
and how research in decision
making and in social psychology
and in economics can help
us understand better how
we choose, why we choose, and
how we think and sometimes
unconsciously don't think about
what we're doing when we're
doing a faculty search.
First I want to start out
by thanking everybody here
who's serving on a
faculty search committee
or is otherwise involved
in faculty searches, which
is everyone in the room.
I would say that the
identification of the Harvard
faculty of the future is one the
most important things that we
do.
And it gives us the opportunity
to reshape the Harvard faculty,
to think about what kinds
of exciting new directions
we want to strike out in and
what kinds of bench strength
do we want to reinforce.
The reality is that
faculty searches
are incredibly time consuming.
I think that anybody
who's chaired
a search, at the
end of the process,
would probably say it's about
the equivalent of teaching
a course.
It requires an enormous
amount of effort.
And we thank you for
your commitment to that.
And it's also why
generations of Harvard
faculty before you sat on
searches that lead to you.
So you can think that
you're basically paying it
backwards or forwards for
people who did for you what
you're doing for the future.
And it's also why the president
and provost review every tenure
appointment at the University.
They have a lot of
things on their plate.
And the fact that they
take the time to do that
speaks to the importance
of faculty searches.
I want to say a
word about diversity
and how we think about it.
I think it's fair to say
that a diverse faculty is
a strong faculty.
And it emerges from the broadest
consideration of talent.
If you think about the
students that you're teaching,
you will always
note that they are
more diverse than your
faculty colleagues
in a faculty meeting.
The broader the pool that
you work from, the better
chance you're going to
have to find the faculty
members of the future that
you're really looking for.
A lot of people think diversity
is a sort of newfangled topic
that we're just talking
about in the last few years.
But in fact diversity has been a
topic about the Harvard faculty
for quite some time.
This quote, which
I will read, comes
from a report was issued in 1938
called the Committee of Eight.
And if anybody
wonders what gave rise
to the ad hoc tenure
review process,
it's not from time in memoriam.
It was a recommendation
of this Committee of Eight
that reported to
President Conant
that we needed new
procedures for identifying
the faculty of the future.
The entire report talks
about faculty search
processes in the early
part of the century.
The appendix, there's
a section on diversity.
It's not about the diversity
that we're used to reading.
And I'll read this to you.
"It is a common opinion
that Jews, regardless
of their qualifications,
have found
it increasingly
difficult to obtain
academic posts in America.
At Harvard, some of the
most distinguished members
of its faculty, past and
present, have been Jews.
The extent to which
antisemitic bias
has come to operate in the
making of junior appointments
is difficult to assess.
Those who raise the issue
seemed in agreement,
to use the words of one of
them, 'that racial prejudice is
so thoroughly ingrained and
taken for granted that no one
takes much notice of it except
in particularly flagrant
cases.' The committee is
informed that certain members
of the faculty object to
the appointment of Jews
to the tutorial staff in
the belief that they are
unacceptable to undergraduates."
And the report goes on and
basically makes a statement
about the value of
diversity and says,
"conscious or
unconscious antisemitism
would be a betrayal to the best
traditions of the university."
It's rather remarkable
in 1938 they were
talking about unconscious bias.
That was an interesting
way of framing it.
I wish this problem went away.
But this is from a search
committee report last year.
This is a direct
quote from the report.
And there are quotes
embedded in it.
So this is a quote from
somebody in the report.
"The following anecdote
makes me a bit unsure
about my and our judgment.
The last African
American candidate
we had was Y. The
consensus was that she
did a very poor job
of fielding questions,
and we wondered about
her quality of mind.
Her paper has now
been published in--"
I'm not naming the
journal, but it's
a top journal in the field.
"Clearly she's been a very
successful academic since"
she went to Yale.
"And with hindsight, I wish
we'd made her an offer.
I wonder whether we're in a
similar situation with X,"
the candidate they're
considering now.
"The committee sought to remove
the weighting of presentation
in its deliberations,
but still felt
that there was
significant uncertainty
about X's future trajectory.
We therefore do not
recommend proceeding with X,
but we would strongly
urge the school
to go back and reconsider Y,"
who oh by the way we rejected
two years ago.
And X is at the University of
Chicago and doing quite well.
This is a conversation I
had with an academic dean
last week.
"I met with--" this is
the academic dean's voice.
"I met with the department
to discuss the two finalists,
X and Y. A distinguished
member of the department not
on the search committee
raised his hand
and said, 'I have
serious concerns
about the process
in this search.
This short list makes
it clear that the search
was referring to start.
How else could the two finalists
be female?'" That's last week.
So clearly there
are issues about how
we search for faculty, how we
think about what we're doing,
and how we can do better
what we're trying to do,
which is build an
outstanding faculty.
The genesis for today's
event came from a topic
that Sheena Iyengar,
one of our panelists,
gave last year at the
Kennedy School on her book
The Art of Choosing.
And in fact she is giving a
public lecture at the Radcliffe
Institute later today if you're
interested in learning more
about it.
The talk was wonderful.
I encourage you
to go to her talk.
And at dinner, with a whole
bunch of decision scientists,
I throw out the question, "How
does your work on decision
science have a role in how we
think about faculty searches?"
And it was an incredibly
lively conversation.
It's what led to
the event today.
Decisions about
faculty recruitment
are fundamentally multivariate--
there are lots of dimensions--
and continuous.
It's not a black
and white situation.
But in the end, we have to
make a yes or no decision
about a particular candidate.
And so it's a very
difficult problem space.
So the kinds of
things that we've
asked our panelists
to talk about today
are what makes for the most
effective search committee.
Should search committees develop
selection criteria in advance,
because after all, don't faculty
members know good faculty
when they see them?
There is this sense that you
already know how to do this.
Do cultural factors
really play a role?
Aren't smart people able to
guard against unconscious bias?
And how do we deal with
search committee dynamics
and the conflicts
that inevitably rise?
And how do we reach consensus
on a decision making process?
I'm going to introduce the
three panelists on your right--
OK, my right there.
Sheena Iyengar, who is the
ST Lee Professor of Business
at Columbia Business School.
She has a 1997 PhD in social
psychology from Stanford.
And as I mentioned
her recent book,
bestselling book,
The Art of Choosing,
examines a whole set of
questions about choice--
how we make choices, the
relationship between how
we choose and who we are,
how we are influences that,
why we're often so
disappointed in our choices,
and how much control do
we really have over them.
In the middle is
Iris Bohnet, who
is a Professor of Public
Policy at Harvard and Director
of the Harvard Kennedy School's
Women and Public Policy
Program.
A 1997 PhD in economics from
the University of Zurich.
Iris's research
combines insights
from economics and psychology.
Historically her work is focused
on trust and its determinants,
and its relevance for
negotiation and decision
making.
More recently-- and she's
going to talk about some
of more recent work-- she
has been focusing on choice
architecture and
knowledge, how outcomes
can be influenced by little
small things in processes.
And finally on the far
right, Mahzarin Banaji,
Richard Clarke Professor of
Social Ethics in our Psychology
Department, and
also Senior Advisor
to the FAS dean on
faculty development.
Mahzarin has a 1986 PhD from
Ohio State in psychology.
And she studies
the mental systems
that operate in implicit
or unconscious mode.
In particular, she's interested
in the unconscious nature
of assessments in self
and other humans that
reflect feelings and knowledge
about their social group
membership.
In her new role, Mahzarin
is working very closely
with the dean of faculty of
Arts and Sciences, very closely
with me and my office, on
trying to identify and challenge
any barriers that stand
in the way of achieving
our goal of having the
most outstanding faculty.
The game plan is that Sheena
and Iris will each speak
for about 20 minutes.
And Mahzarin will make
some concluding remarks
and will moderate
the discussion.
So with that, let me turn
it over to Sheena Iyengar.
[APPLAUSE]
Hello everyone.
So when I got this
email from Judy saying,
will you come and speak
to the various search
committees at Harvard about how
to improve the academic hiring
decision making process--
I'm looking at this email
and extremely intimidated
by this email.
Do I really know enough
to make suggestions
about how to improve academic
hiring decision making
processes?
At the same time, I was
a bit intrigued by this,
by the daunting exercise.
Because as a member of the
decision making research
community, certainly I'm
aware of the various biases
and things that affect our
decisions, whether we're hiring
or whatever decision
we're making.
And we're not always proud
when we see the kinds of things
that bear out in the results.
And then at the
same time, I've sat
on a number of different
search committees,
and now sit on the
P and T and keep
wondering to myself,
how do we improve this?
I mean, how do we debias
everybody so that we actually
make the best choices?
If you look at the research,
I couldn't find a single study
that actually looked at academic
hiring decision processes that
documented the various things
that we do during that process,
although there is a
lot of research that
looks at hiring decision
making processes in general.
And as a quick sort of
thumbnail summary of that,
we see that we make mistakes
every step of the way
in terms of how we go about it.
When we look at resumes
and collect resumes,
white people are 50% more
likely to get an interview
than African Americans.
Men are more likely to get
hired for certain positions
or considered for certain
positions than our women.
Turns out that the actual
sound of your name and letters
that make up your
name can actually
make a difference in
terms of whether you're
likely to be hired or not or
at least interviewed or not.
Then when you look at the
actual interview process,
there's all kinds of
studies that show us things
that we're not quite happy when
we read about that might affect
this like the strength
of someone's handshake
could make a difference.
The first impression you make
in the first minute, perhaps
plus or minus 30 seconds, the
overall 30 minute interview
or, you can imagine,
job talk can actually
affect what you
think of this person.
And studies have shown, at
least in private industry,
that in fact we tend to
overweight those interviews
and think that they're
much more diagnostic
of our performance in the
long run than they really are.
And that in general when it
comes down to interviews,
we tend to like and hire
those people that remind us
of ourselves, have
similar attitudes,
are demographically
more similar to us,
maybe have similar
personalities to us.
Now I look at all this
research and realize oh my god,
there's all these mistakes
that we might be making.
And then I try to debias myself.
And that becomes a rather
daunting, intimidating task,
particularly given that
so many of these biases
happen to us at a rather
subconscious level.
Can I really debias
myself and make
sure that I'm not
going to be affected
by, say, the compliment
that this person gave me
that sounded so genuine?
I mean, aren't I
human in the end?
A few years ago when my
colleagues and I-- and many
of my colleagues were
social psychologists--
and I got together, and
we're trying to put together
the decision making module
for our core course in the MBA
program in
organizational behavior,
we thought about
how were we going
to teach our students about
decision making policies
and how to counteract act.
And we showed them all
different exercises
in which we make them
aware of the various biases
that they engage in.
But then we wanted to
give them an exercise that
felt more real, that was the
kind of exercise they would
be doing in their
real jobs, and also
be able to give them some sort
of heuristics or guidelines
on how they could
improve upon that.
In a nutshell, what
I'm going to show
you is an exercise
which we designed.
And in the designing of that
exercise, what we sort of took
a position as
being is we decided
that it was unrealistic to
take the stand that we're
going to make every single
individual debiased.
We assume that
they'll all be biased.
But that what we could do
was create a decision making
process for the group
in which we could create
an environment and
a set of processes
that people could
employ as a group which
would create an environment
which would result in more
informed decision making.
That was really the
goal that we set out.
So we weren't trying to make
any particular individual less
biased.
If that happens, great.
But what we're
really trying to do
is create a simple set of
decision making processes
at the group level
which will improve
upon the decisions that might
happen at the individual level.
So let me describe
to you this exercise.
And this exercise, while
we adapted it at Columbia,
it's actually not
our possession.
It's adapted from an
exercise that was originally
created actually at Kellogg
and was originally from there.
But the idea of a professor
who is actually at the London
Business School,
an experience he
had in his own personal
life, and that then
turned into an exercise
which has been running around
in different forms
in various schools.
So in this exercise, we
take the MBA students
and we divide them
up into two groups.
And these two sets-- two
different groups types
in fact-- these
groups have to make
a decision about whom to hire.
And they have to
figure out whom to hire
for a senior vice president
position in information
technology.
And these groups are made
up of five individuals.
These five individuals
represent different positions
in an organization--
CFO, head of marketing,
different positions-- head of
sales-- different positions
that you would imagine
at the top of the ranks
in an organization.
And they now have to
decide whom they're
going to hire that's going to be
head of information technology.
Just as you would have in a
normal hiring decision making
situation, all of
these five individuals
have some pieces of
information that's the same.
So they have three candidates,
Sarah, Catherine, and Janet.
So they all have information
that's the same for all three
of these candidates.
But as a function of
their particular positions
and the kind of
information that gets
relayed to them as a
function of their position,
they also have some information
about the various candidates
that's not shared.
So one set of groups engage in
a decision making process that's
like this where they have
five individuals, information
about those three candidates.
Some of that
information is shared.
Some of that information
is not shared.
Another set of groups
have five individuals,
but those five
individuals are given
all of the information
about all three candidates
that is available at
that moment of decision.
So what happens?
Well, what happens-- and we've
been running this exercise now
for a number of years.
And actually what
we find is very
consistent with
the prior research
on this, the research
on hidden profiles
by Stasser and colleagues.
And what we find is
that the groups that
make the decision when they have
some information that's shared,
some information
that's not shared,
you find that 75%
of these groups
hire a woman by the
name of Catherine.
When you have the
groups that had
all the information
at their disposal,
now you find 85% of
them choose Janet.
Now in truth, all three of
these candidates are qualified.
Now let's just look back
at the general information
about these three candidates.
They're all very qualified
candidates, much like sort
of academic possibilities
that we might hire,
academics we might
consider hiring.
So you have three individuals.
They're all perfectly suited
for a senior vice president
of information technology.
One of them is an
external candidate.
Two of them are
internal candidates.
But why is it that when the
information is not shared,
when it's distributed
across individuals,
you see one candidate
chosen, and when
everybody has all
the information,
you see another
candidate chosen?
When you look at the
way the information
is distributed, what you
see is that Catherine
has more positive information
that happens to be shared
across all five group members.
When you look at
Janet, she has a piece
of negative information--
does not recognize
the contributions of others.
That piece of
negative information
is shared across all the groups.
In truth, if all the information
about every candidate
were to have been surfaced,
it looks like Janet probably
has a little bit of an edge.
She has a bit more positive
information associated with her
than, say, Catherine or Sarah,
although you could make a case
for any one of them.
Now in the classroom when
the students come back
and we debrief this exercise,
we find out what they did.
We find out what happened in
those groups that were trying
to figure out whom to hire.
And what we find is in groups
where the information is
distributed, much
like it would be
in a real hiring decision making
process, what did they do?
Well, everybody has
the basic information
about those three candidates.
They start their meeting.
The moderator wants
to be efficient.
And so the moderator
takes a poll.
A reasonable thing
to do, take a poll.
Let's just find out,
where's the consensus?
They take a poll
and they find out,
well you know, people seem to
be generally split on Catherine.
More people usually
want Catherine.
Some people want Sarah.
Maybe one person
on occasion thinks
Janet might look
good, depending on how
much positive
information about Janet
has been shared with
that one individual.
Well now they've made a vote.
Now the moderator says, well,
let's talk about these three
candidates.
Let's figure out what
are their pros and cons.
So they jot down all the
pros and cons associated
with these three candidates.
Well, they jot down
all the pros and cons,
and it becomes
very clear to them
that Catherine is the
dominating alternative.
Sometimes they pick
Sarah, mainly because they
have a little bit of a bias
in favor of an internal person
rather an external person.
But when they come
back to that classroom,
and now I put up all the
information, and I say to them,
did you know
everything about Janet?
And my question isn't, did
you pick the right one.
Are you confident that
you picked the best one?
Because any of them
could be the best one.
My question is
simply, did you have
all the information about Janet
that was available to you?
And second, if you had had
some of this information which
was not available to you
at the time of decision,
do you think it would have
mattered to you while you
were making that decision?
And if the answer to
both of these questions
is no, I didn't have
all the information,
yes it would have mattered,
well then my question
is, did you give
Janet a fair hearing.
And as I said
before, when people
have all the
information, they tend
to be more likely
to choose Janet.
Now we then go on to
do other exercises
and teach them a decision
making process that we think
makes that process
more fair, or at least
gives all of the candidates
more of a fair hearing.
If you remember,
my goal here is not
to debias all the
individuals of the group.
I'm assuming all the
individuals are biased.
My goal is simply to make
sure that every candidate
has a fair hearing.
Why did they not
have a fair hearing
in the traditional model
that they were using?
They didn't go out to be biased.
But what happens?
When you actually
look at the process
that these groups describe
that they used, well,
once you have that vote
out-- I like Catherine.
I like Sarah-- when I'm
surfacing the pros and cons,
I'm more likely to surface
the things that support
what I think to be true.
I'm more likely
to forget whatever
little positive things I know
about Janet, particularly when
a whole bunch of other
people said, you know,
she doesn't recognize
the contributions
of her fellow colleagues.
Yeah, I know, isn't
that really bad?
And then you start having the
Janet sucks song going on.
So that one piece of
negative shared information
ends up becoming more available,
and also gains in weight.
The people that ended
up voting initially
stick to their opinion.
Sort of a commitment and
consistency effect goes on.
They also start
finding information
that's more likely to
support their opinion, known
as confirmation bias.
And also in the end you
try to get some consensus.
There's a sort of Janet
sucks thing going on.
And that ends up looking
like a group think process.
So are there things we can
do with the group level
decision making
processes that we
can put in place that would give
people more of a fair hearing?
So what I'm going to
describe to you now
is a decision making
process that I've
adapted for academic
hiring that's based on what
we use with the MBA students.
By the way, it's also
something that we're actually
employing right now at the
Columbia Business School
as we search for the
candidate for our new decision
making academic hire.
So ask me in a few months
if we were successful.
And what I'd like to emphasize
here is what I'm putting out
here is a proposal.
So you can feel free to--
I'm expecting you to throw
some gentle darts at me.
Feel free to disagree.
It's really I'm trying to
give you food for thought.
So here's my proposal.
Stage one of an academic
hiring process--
you come up with a criteria,
some general criteria.
And at this stage, I
would make that criteria
fairly vague and general.
I'm looking for-- the
best person right now
is the leading scholar in
decision making, negotiations,
broadly defined.
That now gives you the
ability to search widely.
Gather up resumes from as
far and wide as you'd like.
And sometimes people find
it helpful to designate
some members of the committee
to specifically search
for diversity candidate.
And I'd like to emphasize here
that diversity doesn't just
apply to ethnic and
gender distribution.
That's certainly an important
diversity component.
But it also applies
to diversity in terms
of intellectual contribution.
So for example in our current
decision making hiring process,
we've got an
anthropologist on the list,
and we're considering hiring an
anthropologist at the Columbia
Business School that
studies primates and does
brain research and also
does research in economics,
having to do with trust.
So it can be quite diverse
even in terms of intellect.
So now you've got
all these resumes.
And you might actually
have quite a few resumes.
Now if you had a
lot of resumes, we
know from research that
been conducted by me
and a number of other
people, it can kind of
overwhelming if
you suddenly have
to look at, say, a hundred
or even 50 odd applications
and make some real
decisions about who's going
to make it into the short list.
So to avoid a sort of
information overload
or a too much choice overload
effect, what I propose doing
is that we take those
sets of resumes of vitaes,
divide them up across
the committee members
so that no one committee member,
say, has more than 10 or 15,
make it a manageable
set of vitaes.
Each candidate gets seen
by two committee members
so that you don't have any
particular individual that's
going to get killed
as a function of one
particular individual's
preferences in one
or the other direction.
And the committee members
are now given the task
not of saying yes or no, do we
want to interview that person.
That's a little
complicated at this stage.
Instead they're given
the task of simply rating
them high, medium, low-- good
candidate for an interview,
medium, low.
Now you generate these ratings
of high, medium, and low.
You bring them
together in a meeting.
You collate the results.
And now you have a list.
How many made it such that
they were all in the high?
How many were kind of a mix
of highs and mediums, mediums
and lows?
And now you can make
a criteria by which
you're going to cut
out the applicants
that you don't
want to interview.
So again, the task here is
not picking out, initially,
who you are going
to interview, whom
you're not going to interview.
Because that's ultimately
a little bit of an easier
decision to make.
Once you've come up with
a rule by which you're
going to throw out the
candidates that you don't want
to interview, now you've
got a list of candidates
that you think might be
feasible to interview.
At this point, you can
start having the discussion
about what your more
specific criteria is
and use that for
narrowing down that list
of potential
interview candidates
to a more manageable set.
And that committee can decide
what that manageable set is.
Is it going to be five?
Is it going to be seven?
I usually don't
recommend going past 10
because you're just not going to
remember all their interviews.
Your fellow colleagues
aren't going
to remember all
their interviews.
It leaves you open
more to being more
likely to vote in favor of those
candidates that are somehow
more memorable in some way such
that would open yourself up
to a little more bias.
You want to really try to
make the evaluation process as
manageable as possible.
So now let's say you've
decided on your candidates.
You've brought them in for
their various job talks.
They've met with your
fellow colleagues.
You ask your fellow colleagues
to give their opinion
high, medium, low.
Never ask them yea or
nay-- high, medium, low.
Now you come to stage two.
How are you going to decide
whom to get that offer to?
How you going to run that
really critical meetings, or set
of meetings in which
you're going to decide
who to give that offer to?
So when you have that first
meeting, what's your goal?
You goal is not to pick
the best candidate.
Your goal is to give each
person a fair hearing.
So how are you going to do that?
First, you have a specific
discussion about the criteria.
Put that criteria on the board.
And naturally, as
fellow academics,
we're all going to have
strong opinions about what
our criteria should
and should not be.
Some people will weigh
more heavily the importance
of having an internal person.
Some people will weigh
more heavily the importance
of an external person.
Some people will
weigh more heavily
adding strength to an
already existing strength.
Some people will
feel that it's more
important to weigh diversity.
And these are a legitimate
things to value.
The important thing is to get
the criteria out there and get
out there what the trade-offs
are in terms of which things
we value more, which
things we value less.
And it's OK to have some
disagreements up there.
Next thing we put
up-- so at this point
we haven't yet
asked anybody what
they think of the candidates.
Now what we put up
is we ask each person
to surface all the
information that they have
about each of the candidates.
We're not asking them
to give their opinion.
We want to stop them from
giving their opinions.
Just, let's get out
all the information
about all the candidates
under consideration.
After you've surfaced
all the information
that you have possibly available
to you at this moment in time,
about the candidates,
now you're in a position
to start putting evaluations.
And the way we run
the evaluations is we
ask each of the
committee members
to, semiprivately-- meaning on
a private sheet of paper-- rate
the candidates
high, medium, low.
Don't put your name on it.
And hand that to the moderator,
head of the search committee.
That moderator now
collates the results
and puts them up on the board.
The reason why I say it's
semiprivate, because obviously
can I really figure
out who might
have given a little more
preference to one candidate
to another after awhile
of knowing our colleagues?
Of course we all
know, to some extent,
where our colleagues'
preferences lie.
But it's still important to
not have a name attached to it,
put it up on the board,
and have a sense of where
does the group stand.
Around which candidates do
we have more of a consensus?
we have less of a consensus,
much more of a sort of
minority support around?
Once you have those
numbers up on the board--
and again, they're all rated
in terms of high, medium,
and low-- we now first
address the minority opinion.
What does those people that are
supporting the candidates that
are less preferred, what
are their arguments,
so that those arguments
are heard in case
other people still
feel like they
want to change their minds.
That's another reason why you
don't put the name associated
with the opinions or the votes
up there, because it gives
people a chance to possibly
revise their opinion
without loss of face.
So now you have the minority
opinion that's surfaced.
People can think about it.
At that point, we start
discussing the majority
opinion.
And in the process of
discussing the majority opinion,
we also think it's
helpful to do--
what we've been trying to do
anyway at the Columbia Business
School is also surface the
discussion around, well,
say we hire this person.
What do we expect them to
do once they come here?
Are they going to be a good fit?
Is it possible that the research
that they've done that's
been so fascinating
up until this point,
would it continue here?
Would it necessarily have
to change if they came here?
We're being sensitive
to the recent research
on star analysts
that was done here
at Harvard which shows that
when star analysts move
to another organization,
their performance actually
can drop by 20%.
Now can we say anything
meaningful about what
someone's future
trajectory is going to be?
No, we don't really know
for sure what will happen.
But we think it's
useful to at least have
that discussion, to
at least think about,
what are our expectations of
this person once they arrive.
And perhaps that
discussion might bring out
other things we
hadn't thought about,
and might also influence our
preferences towards the end.
In the final stage,
we make a decision.
We try to gauge consensus.
We try to gauge everybody's
voice, everybody's input.
Because in the end
of the day, how well
that candidate will
do at your institution
will depend on
everybody's buy-in.
Only if you cannot get
absolute buy-in do you go with
the majority vote.
We try to reserve that
only for the final moments
if you really can't
get consensus.
Now one of the
things that I think
is really important for us
to do that we don't do and is
probably really scary to
even contemplate doing,
but if we really want to be able
to improve our decision making
process over the
long run, we need
to have a procedure
in place for auditing.
We need to be able to look
back, have a system in place
where we look back, have
the information that we
had at that moment when
we made that decision,
and be able to
audit our decisions.
How did we do that time?
Did we reject somebody
that maybe in retrospect we
should not have rejected?
And to have that
ability, even if you
can't undo that decision, it's
important to be able to audit.
Because when you audit, you
now have more information
about what things you can
avoid doing going forward.
And I'm not saying
that auditing has
to be this formal thing that's
taken over by the provost's
office or by the dean's office.
Do it internally, informally,
within your own departments
just as an internal
check for yourself.
Because ultimately
we all have the goal
of making sure we hire
the very best people that
will contribute the
most to our institution.
So with that, I'm going to
leave it open for discussion.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
Good morning everyone.
It's a great pleasure to
contribute to the discussion
as well and follow
Sheena, who I think
has done such a wonderful job in
helping us think about a better
design for the process.
What I plan to do this morning
is give you some input.
So less of a structure
at how to do this,
but some ideas that just came
out of research in recent years
of what to think about in
terms of improving the process.
In particular I want to
talk about gender equality
nudges and a bit about
why diversity matters
and how we could even
think about the benefits
or the diversity premium.
So "Nudge," I think
most of you are
familiar with Cass Sunstein
and Richard Thaler's book that
has recently come out.
A nudge is a gentle
persuader that
builds on our insides
of how our minds work.
And it's quite different from an
incentive or regulation or even
information, so other
types of interventions
that you could think about it.
In fact better than even trying
to describe what a nudge is,
I want to show
you a short video,
which is a nice illustration
of a little nudge.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[END PLAYBACK]
OK, so this was a video
about the people's choices
between stairs and escalator.
And what the video did
is transform the stairs
into a piano.
So that's what made
it more fun for people
to walk up the stairs.
So that kind of gives
you an idea of the nudge.
We're neither paying
people to do something
nor we're regulating certain
behavior nor are we putting up
a sign there, it's good for
your health to use the stairs.
But we're changing the
environment ever so slightly
to affect people's choices.
And that's the idea behind
gender equality nudges
that we now want to build on.
And so as Sheena-- what we're
arguing is that very rarely
do wrong decisions come about
because people intentionally
try to rig the system or try
to choose the candidate that
was close to their own
interests or any of that sort.
But it really has
much more to do
with how our minds work with
bounds and rationality, will
power, and bounded awareness.
So I have a little illustration
here of that for you
so you can all see it.
Often we do this.
And I though with
the faculty, I'm
not going to do it this way.
But we often do it as
a little experiment
where we ask half the
people to close their eyes
and look at this and
see what they see.
And so what you see, ABC.
And then I would ask the
other half of the room
to close their
eyes and would show
the first half, this number
sequence here, 12, 13, 14.
And of course the middle
number here, the B,
is identical to the
B that you saw here.
So that's just an
illustration of what
you see depends on the context
in which you see something.
Let me give you one
more illustration.
And that is you're comparing
squares A and squares B.
And the question is, what
is the color of square B?
And I would assume most of
you see B as lighter than A
because your minds want to
make sense of the pattern
that you see here.
In addition, being
super smart, you also
want to take into account that
there's a little shadow here,
which might make B darker.
Turns out that when we cover
the surroundings of A and B,
the colors are,
in fact identical.
So again, it really matters
how we look at things
and what you see.
And so, of course in
a picture like this
what you see, who
you see as a leader,
who you see as a follower,
who see as senior, junior,
as attractive, not attractive,
black, white, female,
et cetera depends on
how you look at this.
So that's really
where I want to start.
And I want to talk
about three studies.
And the first one in fact
is the least developed,
but I want to give you the idea.
Because I think particular
for faculty hiring,
this one is actually
an important one,
but I don't have
any results yet.
But here's the idea.
It builds on research in
psychology on variety seeking.
And here's how one of
the early studies worked:
students were given choices
of candies or snacks.
And in one condition, people
had to make a choice for,
let's assume, every
snack for a whole month.
So at the beginning of the
month, I'm given 10 choices.
Here's an apple.
Here's a candy bar.
Here's this or that.
Choose a snack for
every day of the month.
And then in another condition,
a different group of students
was asked every
morning of the month
to choose what snack
to have that day.
And as you might imagine,
in the heat of the moment
that morning, people would
go for their favorite snack
like the Mars bar.
But if you choose at the
beginning of the month
and make 30 choices
at the same time,
people would go for variety.
You can't choose the
same old snack 30 times.
But every morning,
you're kind of
going to go with the same snack.
And you've all been there.
Going back to your favorite
restaurant, every time
you're like, not today.
I'm not going to take the same
thing that I have every time.
But of course that's
what you like best maybe.
So that's known as
variety seeking.
And we want to apply
this to hiring decisions.
And I think the intuition
is very straightforward
that if you hire five
people at the same time,
if you hire in clusters, what's
often known as cluster hiring,
diversity will emerge in a
very different way than when
you hire one person at a time.
So our hypothesis is that
when you hire sequentially,
one person at a time,
we will be much more
likely to go with
our favorite snack,
with our favorite candidate, the
candidate that we're familiar
with, the type of attributes
that we've always hired,
and are possibly
also the least risky.
So that's the
first idea, that we
have to think about how we
hire in terms of do we hire one
at a time or sequentially.
Now a related study,
but in fact building
on a different psychological
mechanism, is our evaluations.
And that's joint work
of Max Bazerman, who's
sitting right there, and
Alexander [INAUDIBLE],
who is a doctoral student
at the Kennedy School.
And here's what we want to do.
We want to look at how we
evaluate the candidates.
And that is now more
about what criteria
do we take into account as
we're evaluating candidates,
and how many candidates do
we look at the same time.
In fact I think I'm going to go
fast forward here and show you
the design so you get a
sense of what we're doing.
So this is a study that we
conducted in the Harvard
Decision Science Laboratory.
And it has the
following scenario.
We first had a group
of people come in.
And they perform a task.
They perform either a math
task or a verbal task.
And these are our agents.
We're actually not
particularly interested
about their behavior,
but we need your data
to know how they
performed in these tasks.
And then you come in.
You come in as the principal
or the hiring agent,
HR officer, or a person who
is responsible for promotion
decision.
And we give you information
of the performance
of these candidates
in this experiment.
And then we're telling
you can now choose one,
and you will be paid based
on that person's performance
in a future round.
So we're not telling you
that the person participated
in this experiment
several rounds.
We're telling you about
their past performance,
but they've also participated
in one more around.
You can choose someone
for this future round,
and you will be paid based
on how well that person did.
And what we're
interested in is what
you based your decision on.
Do you base your decision
on past performance, which
is the right thing
to do, statistically
speaking-- very highly,
highly correlated
with future performance.
So how well you solved the
math problem in the past
is very predictive
of how well you
do that in the future round.
Or do you take other criteria
about that person into account?
And we give you a host of
demographic information
on these people, which
however is identical for all
our candidates but for gender.
So you learn that the
person is a student.
You learn the person's
between 18 and 22 years,
is from the Boston
area, et cetera,
in our case was Caucasian.
Everything's identical
but for the gender.
So we're wondering, do
gender stereotypical beliefs
about performance affect your
likelihood of hiring a person.
So are you more likely to choose
the woman for the verbal task
and the man for the math
task, possibly independent
or disregarding information
of their past performance?
OK, so that's what we do.
And we have a two by
two by two design.
So we have both, as I said,
male and female candidates.
And we have the
following two conditions
where the performance
of the person
was either high, was
a good performance.
And you got
information about that.
So you knew how that
person performed compared
to the mean of the group.
So either it was
a high performer
or it was a low performer.
So you know the person
did worse than the mean.
And your alternative, if
you do not hire the person
is, you go back to the
pool and we pick someone
at random for you.
So you know the expected
value of the pool.
You know an average in the pool.
People for example
found 10 math problems.
This is a personal who found 12.
This is a person who found 8.
And so this is now the
important condition here.
And that is, we're
looking at what
happens when you evaluate
one candidate at a time.
So what if you get
performance information
on the male candidate here,
and you know he's male.
You know he's male, yep.
You know he's male.
That was a deep insight.
And you know how he
performed in the past.
As compared to,
you get information
on two candidates, at least.
Could be more, but at
least two where you can
make comparison information.
So they give you information
on a man and a woman
and how they
performed in the past.
And we're arguing that
comparison information
is going to make your judgments,
loosely speak, more rational.
And what I mean
with that is, you
will be focusing more on
the objective criteria which
in fact are predictive
of future behavior.
OK, so here's what we find.
I'm going to first show
you the separate condition.
Now note, these are equally
qualified candidates.
So you know how well they
performed in the past.
They performed at
the same level.
The likelihood of
choosing a man is 66%,
and the likelihood of
choosing a female is 44%.
Everything absolutely identical.
You get a similar, not
quite as extreme, pattern
for the low performance.
You also note the
performance didn't seem
to matter quite as much here.
But it really was driven
by the gender stereotype.
Now let's compare that
with the joint evaluation
where you compare
two candidates.
The gender bias
completely disappears.
You also know that certainly
as a low performing candidate,
you do not want to
be evaluated jointly.
Because that now
becomes very salient.
Your performance
And people do not hire the
low performing candidates.
And this is now putting
it all together.
Now just quickly so
you get the sense,
this is not just for math.
We actually get the
reverse for verbal.
This was the verbal task.
It was a word find task,
different types of tasks.
Here you have to find nations.
And for example you have
Singapore down here.
And you have to mark the
words that you could find.
So we find reversal
in the gender bias.
Now for verbal tasks, people
prefer the woman to the man
when they evaluate the
person one at a time.
As soon as we evaluate
jointly, the gender bias
goes away again.
So of course that has
implications for hiring
and promotion decisions.
So one question
you may want to ask
yourself is, the
positions you hire for,
are their gender
stereotypically male or female?
Do they fall into the math or do
they fall into the verbal camp?
So for many organizations,
leadership positions
are typically associated with
being in the male domain.
So generally you would
worry based on these results
that promotions to
leadership positions
fall into the math camp.
And so we see those kind of
gender stereotypes emerge.
And of course then
as an organization,
you want to maximize
performance.
You would probably prefer
this joint evaluation
to a separate evaluation,
although there
are many, many reasons here--
and I put them down-- many,
many interest groups
would actually
prefer the separate
evaluation because it
serves them better, in
particular the low performers.
The less qualified people,
for them, it really
hurts to be compared
with the high performer.
OK, so this is an example
of a gender nudge.
You can slightly
change the process
by which you
evaluate candidates,
and we would argue therefore
affect the likelihood
that you base your
decision on stereotypes
or on past performance or
more objective criteria.
I want to end with one
more study here, which
looks a bit more about
effects of diversity
or the balance in a team.
And just a side
comment, if you're
interested in the
benefits of diversity,
a really nice paper is coming
out this month in Science
on the benefits of
diversity in teams, which
I think does one of the best
jobs so far looking across 10
different tasks, in all
kinds of diversity dimensions
kind of looking at what are
the effects of diversity.
And generally there is
the diversity premium.
But diversity, as you
all know, is hard work.
So the question is, is it
more of a public goods problem
where individually we don't want
to actually labor that hard?
Because diversity is hard.
It's hard to work
across boundaries.
But organizationally,
it would actually
be a good thing if we did.
So we want to look at
why does that matter.
And what I'm proposing, in
fact a very, very simple model.
It's a theoretical model
based in information theory
in economics, but we also
test in the laboratory.
And here's just the idea
of what we want to look at.
We're saying that in
many, many situations,
including in academia,
we are in an environment
that you might want to call up
or out, where it's a tournament
style environment
where either you
get the big price,
which is tenure,
or you go someplace else.
You make get tenure there.
But it's up or out.
So that's the kind of
environment we want to study.
And in this environment,
a very simple way
to look at the environment
is that the likelihood
of getting tenure,
the output has
something to do with the
effort that we put in.
But there's this
random component
that we're not
particularly interested in.
And hopefully a big fraction
of the output is due to effort,
but there's also some randomness
involved in the process.
And the main argument
that we're making
is that information
that you have
about this random component has
something to do with how many
like you are around.
So think of the
following situation.
You're trying to get information
on the tenure process.
You're a junior faculty member.
And as it just happened to
me recently, as Judy knows,
you get an email.
I'm chairing a
committee right now.
You get an email
from the candidate.
What information is available?
Could we get access
to other statements
from the past, research
statements, et cetera,
et cetera.
Now it turns out
that that information
is kind of implicitly available,
but you have to ask for it.
Now often the asking
happens along gender lines
or racial lines, or
even nationality lines,
also disciplinary lines.
And the person more
naturally to ask for help
often is someone who is like me.
And there's a lot of research
on networks and mentoring,
et cetera, which suggests
that that's true.
But also in this case
it in fact was true.
And then there's another
piece of evidence
that is based on the Hannah
Riley Bowles' research, who
is at the Kennedy School.
It's harder for women to ask.
You may also know the
book by Linda Babcock,
Women Don't Ask, because
there's social consequences
if you do ask.
So I think this is a
bit of a side comment.
But as I'm thinking about our
hiring and promotion procedures
and tenure evaluations,
that is something
that I urge us to
think hard about.
What information is
explicitly available,
and what is
implicitly available?
What do people have to ask for?
And what if there are
differences in your ability
to ask because of who you are or
because of the network that you
are in because there are
fewer people like you around?
And Judy, in fact she
had an interesting story,
if I may share that,
gave a presentation
with a male faculty member.
And they totally shared
the presentation.
She said, and then
interestingly enough,
afterwards there
was a line of people
who wanted to talk to
the authors of the study,
and totally gender segregated.
The women would talk
to Judy and the men
would talk to him,
although the study had
nothing to do with gender.
So I think I wanted to trigger
your thinking a little bit
of, so how does it matter who
else is in the room or who else
in the team?
So for us in our model,
we're arguing this
is an informational argument.
I'm sure there's
many others-- just
an informational arguments.
So I'm better informed
about this random component
here, the things
that are maybe not
quite as transparent,
the more people like
me are around because I
can ask them for advice.
I can get information
on what to do,
what is available
and not available.
And I don't want to walk you
through the whole study here.
But that's exactly what we find.
So we create groups,
majority groups
which are better informed
on that luck component,
that random component.
And we create groups
which are worse informed
on that random component.
And we find that this
affects their performance.
In fact I'm going to go
fast forward here if I can
and just show you the
final results here.
So what you have here
is the large group,
the majority group
which is better
informed, and this is an
indicator of their performance.
Turns out that we
always find this gap,
this informational
gap is just due
to informational differences
about this more random
component in this process.
So with that, let me conclude.
Gentle changes in
procedures can really
have quite dramatic impact
we would submit to you.
So we know the choice
of comparison sets
affect the likelihood
of being hired.
So just to think about how
you look at candidates.
You look at them one at a time.
Do you compare them?
Do we have comparison
information
as part of our process?
What does that look like?
Do we leave it up to
the letter writers
to choose their own
comparison group,
or do we give the
comparison group?
Really think hard
about comparisons
and how you're using them.
And then secondly
just an illustration
of how the gender balance,
or diversity more generally
in teams, might affect
people's performance
due to these informational
differences between the two
groups.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
My mother taught
me to speak loudly,
so I don't need a microphone.
Let me just begin by
saying that we really
have to recognize that we are
in a very, very different place
now than groups of people who
sat in this very room 10 and 20
and 30 years ago
might have been.
And we have to begin
with that difference
because without that kind
of optimism, that we're
different from them,
it will be hard to make
the kind of progress that I
believe that we need to make.
We're different from
them in two ways.
We're different because
our conscious minds
have changed dramatically.
If I showed a list of what
people like ourselves believed
in the 1950s about groups of
people, you would be shocked.
In fact, I'm glad
Judy started this
by pointing out what
antisemitism in places
like Yale and Harvard was like.
I'll point out a
book by Dan Oren,
written many years ago now
called Joining the Club-- A
History of Jews at Yale.
And as I read it, I just
especially remember this one
page where he
literally just xeroxed
a copy of an application form
and the reason for rejection
in it.
And some professor
at Yale had scrawled
in the box that said
reason for rejection,
has a Mediterranean nose.
That was, at Yale-- and I'm
going to argue, I think,
here too-- a sufficient basis
for rejecting a candidate.
We are not those people.
We no longer not only
say things like that,
we don't believe them.
We would frown upon people
who say things like that.
But I'm going to argue that
even antisemitism hasn't gotten.
All you had to do is listen
carefully to liberal NPR
during the Bernie Madoff weeks.
And here it's surfacing
again to the top
as if it had not gone away.
So I'm here to say these
things, that our minds have
two very different modes
in which they function.
There is a conscious mode.
Think about Abraham
Lincoln, the emancipator,
and know that we have the
emancipator in each of us.
But we also have in
each of our minds
Abraham Lincoln who believed
that black and white could
never be equal, that one
was superior to the other,
that they could never work
together, let alone ever marry.
We carry that in
each of our minds,
and we had better know that.
And this is one of
the ways in which we
are different from
our predecessors,
that we're not going
to be happy just saying
that because I don't
say Mediterranean nose,
I no longer have these biases.
We do.
We have tons of them.
What's
So what's second way in
which we're different?
We're different because
even 10 years ago,
there was not a
science of this stuff.
What Sheena and what Iris
and what others have now
demonstrated for us
is that just as we
can be great physicists and
great people who understand
strategy and finance and
medicine, because we are
schooled in those
methods, that likewise
we have to be schooled, every
one of us to some extent,
in the processes
of decision making.
Because there is a science.
It can tell us about
the right and wrong ways
to make decisions.
And we have to hold ourselves
to a higher standard
because this knowledge
was simply not available
even a few years ago, let
alone a few decades ago.
So our responsibility
is greater.
If I had to leave you
with like a few ideas
that we might use to
have a discussion--
and my job really
is to just help
moderate a discussion
between our two
amazing speakers
and you as you begin
to think about
searches-- could I just
say that I think the first
thing to keep in mind
is that you as
chairs of departments
and as members of
search committees
automatically
become conservative
when you're put in that role.
Social psychology will tell
you over and over again
that we believe that the font
or the source of behavior
information or action
lies in individual people,
but we don't
recognize the extent
to which power and
source of influence
lies in the situation.
By putting you on a
bicycle and having you
race around Cambridge, we can
make you hate car drivers.
As soon as we put
you in a car, we
can make you hate people like
me who race around crazily
on a bicycle.
I mean, these are
simple roles that we
play that have very powerful
effects on what we like,
who we think is good, and so on.
And one of the things
I'm very concerned
about-- because I have seen
it happen to me-- that I
am unwilling to even
use the word risk
or risky when I'm on
a search committee.
But being outside
the search committee,
I'm perfectly happy to say,
let's try this new thing.
So I just want you to be aware
that when you are in that role,
you will never want
to make a false alarm.
You'd rather have a miss
because letting somebody good
go away to Stanford you
will say is not as big
a problem as having
some dud here stuck
with us for the next 50 years.
And so you will-- you
will be pushing very hard.
And I'm just going to ask
that you consult very broadly
to know that while you
should be carefuf--
and I do believe with you that
for us, the criterion should
be one where a miss is
better than a false alarm.
So I'm not asking
us to change that.
But how we think
something is a false alarm
or when we think
something's a false alarm is
really dependent on the type
of person we're looking for.
And that's something
we're going to have to do.
So believe in this, the
power of situations,
and analyze the
situation for what
it's doing to you as you
make these decisions.
The second point
that I want to make
is that we all carry a
model of what success means.
And that model is hugely
powerful in guiding
all sorts of search processes.
You know, I was at
Vanderbilt University
speaking to their
medical school last week.
And I remember thinking as
I was being asked questions
in deeply Southern accents,
I thought to myself,
maybe at Harvard we've gotten
over a lot of different kinds
of biases.
But I bet that this
person asking me
a perfectly good question could
never get a job here because
to us, a Southern
accent is correlated
with many other
things that we truly
believe is not smart, has
different values, and so on.
And so I'm just bringing
this up because I
want you to think about
diversity in a much broader way
then we have.
I have a colleague who looks
to you very mainstream--
white, male, Protestant,
six feet, six inches tall.
And yet he walks around Harvard
feeling like he doesn't belong.
And he feels that because
he's a farm boy from Illinois,
and he grew up on a small farm.
And he says, you
know, I never fit in.
In rooms like this, I feel
I'm going to drop something
or I'm going to
say something that
isn't like how people--
he's been here for 20 years
and for the previous 20 at Yale.
But he still believes that he's
this bumbling farm boy who is
going to say something stupid.
What I want to take
away is that this person
is very valuable
to the university
because one of things
he does is he never
toes the line in any way.
He's the first one to
say to us, you guys
just don't think this way,
because he carries around
in his mind this view that he's
different from the rest of us.
And so he's very valuable
to us because he will not
take any decision at
face value and will
probe a little bit more.
And I'm going to ask us
that we-- diversity needs
to be thought about in
a whole variety of ways.
And finally I want to say,
don't trust people like me.
Don't trust people who look like
they're women, people of color,
and that we will do what's
right for our groups.
We won't.
We too have in our minds
embodied the very same things
that you regard to be important.
And we will make the
same mistakes with you
unless we are all being
educated to be different.
So I have developed
a set of tests
that will teach us something
about what's in our minds.
I encourage you to
take those tests,
because you may discover
that as somebody white,
you actually don't
have a pro-white bias.
As somebody black, you may
actually have a pro-white bias.
And you need to know what's
in your individual minds
as you go forward in
making these decisions.
So with that, let me just say
that keeping in mind that there
are situational influences
that we embody in us models
of things that are
good that are actually
very much the
standard is something
that we have to worry about.
And finally I will
say that familiarity
is a hugely powerful
motivator of behavior.
There's a lovely
New Yorker cartoon
that has two snails
talking to each other,
looking at a large
tape dispenser.
And one snail says
to the other snail,
"I don't care that
she's a tape dispenser.
I just love her."
And I think that this
is what happens to us.
When we see tape dispensers
that look like ourselves,
our heart just
rushes out to them.
It could be anything that
makes the familiarity.
Their eyes could be the same
color as our mother's eyes.
Their father may have
gone to the same school
that you went to.
You may both love
classical music.
These are the kinds of things
that make interviews be deadly.
And we base so much
on the interview.
And there are good data to
suggest that unless each of us
is schooled in performing
structured interviews,
that the interview plus
resume leads to worse
decisions than resume alone.
And we'd better know that
before we spend the kind of time
that we do on talks
focusing on things
like physical form, accent,
where somebody's come from,
and so on.
So I'm just putting
these out for you
because the job
we're now telling
you have is far
bigger and far harder
than you might have thought.
You can ask yourself,
what am I supposed to do,
like think about every
one of these things?
How am I ever going
to make a decision?
Well, we'll do it, and we'll do
it better than people before us
did because we have
knowledge that they didn't.
So with that, I'm going to stop.
And I'll tell you that
we'll open this up
for at least a few minutes of
questions to our two panelists.
And I will help moderate.
So just raise your hand.
And also ask
questions of the kinds
of things you would want
the administration to do.
Today you heard about things
like multiple searches
at one time may be better
than one after the other.
Well maybe our deans
need to know this.
And maybe they need to
figure out ways with us,
but how to construct
searches so we can maximize
the possibility of these.
So feel free to raise anything
you want, and I'm sure Sheena
and Iris will answer them all.
Yes.
Just stand up and ask question
so we know who you are.
A few times the phrase
objective criteria came up.
And I was wondering if you could
say a bit more about what that
means in the context
faculty searches,
both in the initial stage one
of filtering out applications,
and also later
when one is trying
to draw the line between
perhaps legitimate questions
of collegiality
and whether someone
will be a good citizen
in the department
and interact with others
and inappropriate criteria
that we don't want to be using
that becomes very close when
you start thinking about fit.
Let me try and take
a first try at this.
So certainly in our
experiments that
was very easy to delineate.
I completely here
you that in search
processes, in
evaluation procedures,
that's much harder to do.
So I think the first step
might be along Sheena's lines,
really to think about what
are the criteria that we want
our decisions to based on,
to think hard about what
are those criteria.
And I think we all can have
some sense of publications,
et cetera, citations
and other things
that we might care about.
And to have the discussion of
what are we worrying about,
and then get a sense
of how much weight
should be put in all of these.
Just one additional
comment, I think
there are situations
where it's very obvious
and then there's
others where it's not.
But I'm thinking of
Claudia Goldin's work
on blind auditions
of orchestras where
it was pretty clear that
the decision should not
be based on the gender of
the race or anything else
but how good a violinist
that person is.
And of course the
blindness-- if anything
we haven't mentioned
that because it's not
very practical-- but
that blindness is really
the only way that I
believe, at this point,
we could really
overcome our biases.
I mean, everything
else we're proposing
I think are improvements.
But at the end of the day,
we're all part of this society,
and therefore we'll
fall into these trap.
So my view on this is that
the point at which you
can be, quote, unquote,
objective-- and objective is
also sort of a subjective term--
is in that process where you're
looking at those initial
vitaes and you're
evaluating who's going to
make it into the short list
to interview, I think
at that point for that,
you can come up with
more measurable criteria.
You can create quantitative
measures of, say, publication
record, impact on the field.
Whether you believe
in citation hits,
I mean that's obviously always
been a controversy depending
on field.
Like always the operations
people are anti-citation hits
and the psychologists
are pro-citation hits.
And so then you
never quite know how
to get your head
around that one.
But to the extent that
the particular group has
a set of measurable
criteria that you
can use to do that high,
medium, low on the vitaes,
I think at that
stage it's helpful.
I think once you get to
that short list of people
that you're into
reviewing, it's probably
fair to say that you're
interviewing people
that are probably all great.
I presume you won't
be interviewing them
if they haven't met the bar.
And at that point what
is, quote, objective,
which is even more
subjective, is
what I was talking about
before in stage two,
is coming up with
as much as possible
your specific
criteria as to what
you're looking
for, acknowledging
the disagreements.
But at least once you have
that specific criteria,
you're now focusing
everybody's attention
towards those criteria.
And now while surfacing
the information related
to the different
candidates, you're
forcing the people
doing the evaluating
to think about those candidates
in terms of that criteria
that they just talked about.
So that's why I said first
board have the criteria,
second board have
the information
about the various
candidates surfacing,
and then do the
semiprivate vote.
I mean, that's
about as objective
I can make a subjective
evaluation process to be.
Yeah, and next you.
The question I have is
recommendation letters
play a huge role
in a lot of this,
reference letters from faculty.
And I'm worried a lot
about bias in that process.
So partly we know
certain faculty.
We trust them.
And sure, there
are biases in how
we form those relationships.
But also, the letters
must inherently
reflect biases of
the letter writers.
So I'm wondering whether
learning about this stuff,
we should be downgrading
those letters
relative to their current role,
which is really quite dominant,
at least in economics for sure.
Yeah, go ahead Sheena.
This is always very hard.
And that's why I
had said earlier
that I gave up on this goal
of trying to completely
debias individuals or even
debias the individuals making
up the group.
So I would say in
your process, you're
gathering up different
bits of information.
You're gathering up
those reference letters.
I wouldn't remove them, because
that's still information.
I mean you really don't
want to have somebody that's
thought of as not capable of
doing research on their own
or producing a
paper on their own.
So that's still
valuable information,
but that shouldn't be the only
information that you're using.
So you're gathering
up the various bits
of information, and when
you set up your criteria
as to what you're looking
for, at that stage you
can specify which
bits of information
are more or less important, and
then surface the information
related to each candidate.
So at least whatever
information you do have there,
it's all getting
considered in that process.
But I agree with you that the
letter writer will be biased.
Each individual on
the committee will
be biased towards their
favorite letter writers.
And I think that's just a given.
And what you hope is that by
creating the decision making
process which is including
everybody's opinion-- which
is all the committee
members-- as well
as all the bits of information
about each candidate,
that that combination
will enable
you to make a more informed
decision that gives
each candidate a fair hearing.
Mahzarin, could I just add
one more thing to that.
And I don't also have
a silver bullet at all.
And I think a lot
of biases there.
I don't think you want
to give up on them,
because the other bias
we're worried about
is of course in group bias.
So you need to have
some outsiders who
are not part of the institution
to give you some feedback.
And I also think one way
to at least them hopefully
improve the quality
of the letters
that you get a little bit is
diversity on the evaluation
committee where we
know, as I said,
we tend to know people
from our own genders,
from our own disciplines, maybe
even more importantly, but also
from our own nationalities
and educational backgrounds.
So therefore I think the
broader you can reach out
to different sets of
evaluators, the more likely
you'll get a good outcome.
Let me just add something
to what you just said.
And I don't have any
research to back this up.
I'm just going to tell
you about our experience.
One experiment we are trying
at the Columbia Business School
is we do have a very,
very diverse committee.
So we're hiring this
decision making person.
We have one finance
person, one economist,
one operations researcher,
one marketing person.
And then we have management
and faculty on this.
So it's a really intellectually
diverse group of people.
And so of course
every committee member
has their own
favorite candidate.
That's a given.
And of course every
single committee member
has their own biases
about how they
want to interpret good and bad
quality research, et cetera.
And I would say that
diversity has been good
so far in that
it's been surfacing
a lot of interesting candidates
that we previously might not
have thought about.
But I think in order
for it to work,
you have to have a moderator
that makes it a point
to not being in favor of
any particular candidate
and who sticks to process.
Because if at any
point the moderator
loses control of
that process, I do
think that having
a diverse group
is a great recipe
for greater conflict.
And can I add to that by saying
that these biases that we
have exist for a reason.
They're not absolutely nutty.
They're there because in some
old world, they helped us.
They helped us pay
attention to those people
will looked like
us who were going
to be less likely to kill us.
It's just that now we
don't live in the world
where people who
look just like us
are any less likely
to kill us than--
And so I'm going to argue
that these things that
used to really pay
off no longer do
because we have to look
at somebody very different
from us.
And a business person has to
say, can I outsource to them
and make a lot of
money off of them.
You have to make decisions
that are of that kind.
And that is why we're
saying, let's examine them.
So one way around
this problem is
that we will not be able to get
rid of these sorts of biases.
We can do the most blatant ones.
But another way around
it, if we're smart,
is to multiply biases, that
is to say multiply them
across people so that different
biases are present in the room,
so that I will say this
is the best person for us
and somebody else will
say absolutely not,
there's somebody else
who's even better.
Yeah, one, and then you.
Peter Manuelian.
I think you said
a general reaction
in situations where a search
committee tends to find
[INAUDIBLE].
And I've heard
arguments on both sides.
One may say, well
this looks real
bad on the search committee.
They're punting the decision.
They're punting upstairs.
[INAUDIBLE]
Or I've heard the opposite that
this is really a good thing
to do and at least we'll
guarantee ourselves
a finalist and a choice
rather than the second,
have one person who
runs [INAUDIBLE]
that person be rejected.
[INAUDIBLE]
I actually like the
idea a great deal.
I like the idea.
And I go back to
what Sheena said.
By the time we're
bringing people out,
they're all very, very good.
They're very strong on paper.
We know the work.
But, this is where the
conservatism of being
on a committee kicks in.
One of them does become favored.
And the difference between them
gets magnified in our minds
in ways that are
absolutely irrational.
And this is where I do
believe that forcing
a committee, by
forcing at as much
as you can force a herd of
squirrels, which is what
faculty are, you can
sort of say look,
this is to your advantage.
You want to educate the
president and the dean
about a whole field.
It's really important
for you to give them
multiple candidates
because who knows,
you may actually be able
to hire more than one,
or if not this year in
the future or whatever.
And I do believe that
keeping that open
and not basically locking
into a single person
is going to pay off for
us in many, many ways.
And I'm watching our
administration do this.
When they look at a
short list and when
they look at the letters
that have come in,
even if there's a
favored candidate,
I hear the dean asking,
but what about this person
who's not number one.
Why?
What makes this person, he
or she, be number three?
And is it really
number three, or is it
only number three with the
frame you're currently using
and with a slightly different
frame, that person may
get bumped up to number one.
And what are we're
going to do now
that we've heard, after
the letters were written,
that she won a MacArthur
Award or something like that.
All of those sorts
of things I think
administrators can help us do.
So yes, you had a question.
I had a question,
two part question.
I've been asked to
chair the [INAUDIBLE]
for all ranks [INAUDIBLE].
So we, in principle, could
hire a professor [INAUDIBLE]
for tenure.
We could also hire a PhD.
And could that then
add one more complexity
in comparing candidates?
I wonder if you had
any advice on that.
And the second is, we have
a student advisory committee
[INAUDIBLE].
And if you had any advice on how
we could construct it to have
them contribute to the process.
So actually we did
recently struggle
with the first of
your two questions.
There were a few candiates--
back to this decision making,
hiring decision making process.
We had a bunch of candidates.
They were all great.
And they ranged anywhere
from just out of PhD
to maybe might be
ready for early tenure
to very, very, very senior.
And in everybody, it looked
like it would come down
to people having different
sort of preferences, et cetera.
And it looked like
it was probably
going to become a very
contentious discussion.
And what I-- and again, I don't
have any research to back this
up-- what I proposed,
and which ended up
happening to simplify the
decision-- because I feel when
possible, try to come
up with decision rules
because people are more likely
to agree on decision rules.
And so the decision
rule I proposed
was that we not lump people
of all different ranks,
that it would just make the
discussion too unwieldy.
Let's just start with
the senior people.
They're more comparable.
You have an easier
evaluation process.
If we don't succeed
on the senior level,
then we'll go to the next level.
So at least in my sort
of biased opinion,
I wouldn't try to
compare all three sets.
It's just too complicated.
I wanted to add something in
particular, and responding also
to the previous question
about the two candidates.
So part of our research suggests
that comparison information
is a good thing.
And I think generally that's
what the research suggests.
However, of course,
you can craft
comparison sets strategically.
So I just wanted us
to be aware of that,
that you can also make
your preferred candidate
shine more if you choose
the appropriate comparison
strategically.
So comparisons are
not just always good.
But if you'd be very honest
about the comparison set,
the research suggests
that it will actually
improve the outcome.
Can we take one more
question, and then Judy
will say few words in closing.
Yes, why don't you come up
here and ask your question
and close.
Picking up on what Iris said
about access to information,
one question that
comes to mind is,
should we share with
potential candidates--
especially in junior searches--
what the criteria are?
In other words, should we try
to make it more standardized,
the experience that
people have coming here,
or are we better off
withholding that because that's
an internal discussion about
what's going on in the school?
When you say criteria, do
you mean criteria for--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
--tenure?
The criteria.
The tenure criteria?
Not the tenure criteria,
the objective criteria
that you're developing
in your search.
Ah, I see.
I do have something to say.
Can I do that?
I think that the nature of our
work is such that we cannot
have a clear set of criteria
that we can lay out there.
There is a bit
there that is fuzzy.
And that's both
good intellectually,
but it is what's going
to make us be more biased
in certain ways.
So I have a lovely
study for you that
was done at Yale University.
It was done by Geoff Cohen and
Eric Uhlmann in which they took
a very masculine profession
like police work,
and they gave people
two candidates.
And one was male,
one was female.
And in some cases, the
male was book smart
and the female was street smart.
And in the other case,
it was the reverse.
And what they discovered
that was just really striking
is that if the male
was book smart,
people said this job
needs a book smart person.
If the male was
street smart, people
said this job needs a
street smart person.
And what they argued is that
what we're doing in our minds,
because we're so smart
about turning things around
to get the outcome that
we think is the right one,
that we're literally fitting the
criterion to the person and not
the person to the criterion.
And I'm going to argue that
this is something where
we will be helped, at least
by putting-- so they actually
showed a lovely reversal.
You lose the bias if
you make people say up
front, what are you
most important criteria.
Then the candidates
are presented,
and then you make a decision.
And so I kind of
take this point,
even though I think
that for us it's
going to be awfully hard to lay
out what those criteria are.
But at least to
ourselves, it might
be useful to know that
we said A is important.
And now we're
actually preferring B
because it might be
the candidate that's
making us go in that direction.
I guess I would add to what
Mahzarin just said and also
say that I would not give the
criteria to the candidates
because once you've stated
the criteria up front,
you're giving less
wiggle room later on.
I would have that discussion
internally about your criteria
so that you all
know, but I don't
think I would reveal
that to the candidates.
Well, I see we've
run out of time.
I want to keep this on schedule.
So I want to thank
everyone for coming,
everyone who's chairing
a search committee
or is working on
a search process,
and especially our panelists,
who I think have given us
wonderful food for thought.
We're going to be putting
this video up on the web.
I encourage you to get your
colleagues to watch this.
We'll also be making available
the slides and other resource
material that really talk
about how research can
inform how we do our processes.
So I want to thank everybody,
and especially our panelists
for coming.
[APPLAUSE]